every meme is in the same typeface it's
called impact but how did that happen
impact was designed by Geoffrey Lee in
1963 it was bold condensed and
sans-serif in line with the style the
60s and ideal for short pieces of text
and punchy headlines impact was
influenced by a movement called the
international typographic style or Swiss
style which emphasized readability and
cleanliness with typefaces like
Helvetica and universe it took those
staid fonts and gave them a dash of mod
flavor those were the days of metal
typesetting so Lee had to carve each
letter by hand
Lee sold it to the type manufacturer
Stevenson Blake this is their original
ad for the font impact was later sold to
mana type another typeface company
they're known for creating times new
roman' and mana type in turn license
fonts to Microsoft so that's how impact
ended up being included in the Windows
operating system which was starting to
dominate the market in the 90s and in
1996 Microsoft chose the Levin core
fonts for the web a free standard font
pack that would work across the internet
impact was one of them by the way that's
webdings that distribution advantage
helped impact become the default in
online forums those memes were called
image macros after macro instructions
the term in computer science for a line
of code that requests a predefined
sequence of instructions and in 2003 in
one of those image macros a picture of a
cap with the words I Can Has Cheezburger
launched the wave of modern means
several mean generator sites
subsequently adopted impact as well
adding a black outline on the white font
there are more than 11 fonts on the
internet now but we expect memes to look
a certain way and that includes impact
and that's probably not going to change
anytime soon like this
yeah